there's a big trend right now in the ipo
world
the latest company to go public through
a spec
ipo spax for many many years had a very
bad name
over the last two years companies like
nikola draftkings
and virgin galactic have all entered the
market through something called spax
or special purpose acquisition companies
these controversial entities
also known as blank check companies
offer private businesses a fast track to
going public that bypasses the
traditional ipo
process and they're growing more popular
you can see activity has almost
quadrupled so far in 2020. some
investors see a big opportunity in spax
and say they're a more efficient way for
companies to go public but critics say
they allow for backdoor deals and that
they're not worth the risk
one criticism of this back process is
that investors
can get into a company and then get
burned they won't have the time to
figure out if it's really a legitimate
company and there is even a risk of
fraud
to understand why investors are rushing
to blank check companies despite the
potential risks
first you need to understand how they
work
[Music]
spax are public shell companies that
exist for a single purpose
finding a private company and taking it
to market quickly
in order to take a company public a spac
will merge with it
the company then gets a spot on the
exchange and a new ticker
the spac transforms into the target
company taking on its name
once the deal closes investors who own
shares in the blank check company
now own a piece of the new entity and
the founders of the spac
get a large part of it too often at a
very good price
blank check companies are primarily
owned by veteran corporate leaders
and big investors like private equity
firms usually it's a smaller amount of
shares that are available to the public
ideally a spac gives you an opportunity
to invest
in a good management team or in a good
entrepreneur
where you have a good feeling about them
doing some sort of profitable deal
that increases the value of the
investment but it is
writing a blank check you're taking a
risk you don't know if they're going to
do a good deal and have the stock go up
or if they're going to do a bag deal and
the stock will go down for the companies
going public spax offer a different
approach than traditional ipos
where the private company works with
underwriters or investment banks to work
out a deal
and then takes the company public the
process can take months
and under traditional ipo rules the
private company must stay quiet and
refrain from promoting its shares
until they start trading this is where
spax have a big advantage with a spac
deal
companies can actually talk about
themselves and promote themselves to
investors
in a way that they can't with an ipo
analysts say growing mainstream
acceptance of spax
helped fuel this year's boom but it was
also the coronavirus pandemic
we are looking at another day of extreme
volatility stocks opened
just moments ago with the dow down more
than 600 points
this is because during volatile markets
a company's valuation can crash
overnight the main advantage to going
public through a spec that's been
definitely true this year
is there's more certainty of execution
you know earlier on in the process that
you'll get the deal done
ipos get derailed at the last minute all
the time
because the markets are volatile they're
falling nobody wants to go public
and this year many of the companies
going public through spax are seeing big
valuations
in september united wholesale mortgage
agreed to go public in the biggest spac
deal ever with a 16 billion dollar
valuation
this is a sharp change from the early
days in the 1980s when the precursors of
today's spacks were called blind pools
these had a shady reputation tied to
penny stock frauds
but in the decades since new laws and
regulations helped add credibility
and bolster investor confidence now as
spax gained momentum more blue chip
institutions
and veteran investors are buying in for
instance goldman sachs never used to
underwrite spac ipos
a few years ago it did its first spac
ipo
uh the new york stock exchange now lists
a lot of specs for a long time it did
not
and with spac funds getting larger the
size of blank check deals are expected
to grow
as well this year bill ackman launched
the biggest spec
ever it could potentially take a very
very large company
public our thesis here is by having a
five billion dollar
cash pile in a public company it's
really
it's our own version of a unicorn still
some critics remain concerned that
companies going public through specs
aren't getting as much scrutiny as those
using traditional ipos
exhibit a for that might be the
situation with nikola which went public
through a spac
a few months ago and has turned out to
be the center of a firestorm of fraud
allegations
nicola shares are tumbling after a short
seller called the company quote an
intricate fraud built on dozens of lies
the people who don't like spax and
prefer traditional ipos would tell you
that if it had gone through a
traditional ipo there had been more time
for investors to kick the tires
and to scrutinize the company for fraud
before it went public
federal regulators are raising concerns
as well
the sec is now examining how blank check
companies disclose
their ownership and how compensation is
tied to an acquisition
we want to make sure that investors
understand those things
and then at the time of the transaction
when they vote
that they're getting the same rigorous
disclosure
that you get in connection with bringing
an ipo to market critics also say
spax have often been a bad deal for
companies going public
the founders of the spac when they do a
deal they get to have a 20
stake in the company that results from
the deal
uh without having to pay very much for
it and it's essentially a way they can
line their own pockets
but this is starting to change ackman's
blank check company
is one of the largest to not include
this feature if bill ackman spec
succeeds in getting a large
multi-billion dollar private company and
taking it public
uh i think it will be the best proof of
concept yet for the spa
idea but right now the future of blank
check companies remains unclear
investors say spac deals are here to
stay while critics argue that the blank
check boom
is just that a trend that isn't destined
to last
you